good morning John I hope that you don't
mind but today I want to give you an
update on the things that I'm doing and
there are a lot of them so let's start
in the middle 2d glasses is the weirdest
thing that I've ever done everyone in my
town now knows me as the 2d glasses guy
which is funny because it like makes no
money and it is not how I think of
myself but it's like all my technophobic
outdoorsy montana friends finally found
something that I do that they can
understand I don't watch a lot of
YouTube videos mostly the ones of me
that they watch are when I'm humping
things or wearing a dress that's why I
love you nerdfighteria yeah I don't have
to wear a dress to get you to pay
attention I will though if you need me
to hey games is going swimmingly right
now on Hank games we have the miracle of
Swindon Town Katherine is now playing
Skyward Sword by herself Katherine and I
are playing Super Mario Brothers we
which is probably the funniest thing
that has ever happened to me and I'm
black really cuz J my Minecraft
experience is going well it's not going
on Hank games I will show you a little
footage I just worked all weekend to get
my nether portal working your pants the
fight to bring back your pants continues
and I seriously apologize that it has
taken this long and it turns out that
the huge load of nerd fight arity in
your pants is just really read it first
I remain committed to its vision but
John was supposed to be riding them
during like the height of signing
psychosis or they didn't like turn out
like we were expecting them to but we
will re-energize read it first and if
you are committed to the magician
magician mission mission not magician if
you're committed to a magician that's
also fine I I wish the two of you the
best if you're committed to the mission
free - first I commend you and Reid Hugo
cabaret cause it's awesome URL Tron the
thing that turns you tumblr very simply
into a.com domain name launch was good
but not a lot of people did and I think
it's probably cuz was too expensive so
now I'm taking the price from $30 to $15
which is now both super convenient and
super cheap so if you're interested in
that URL Letran com VidCon is now like
one half sold out so you better get to
dick I'm constantly working on ideas for
what to do with VidCon if you have any
ideas we have a thing on our Facebook
page I'll put a link to it you can
submit ideas you can also ask a
questions and we'll answer those
questions truth or fail now has over 130
thousand subscribers I just did one on
the Muppets because that movie was
amazing dftba records is celebrating its
third anniversary which is crazy to me
it seems like not long ago at all that
alan and i decided that we needed to do
this thing create great products for
people that they would love and to help
YouTube creators people to do this thing
this thing right here for a living
without having to sell off little pieces
of their soul and we're having a third
anniversary Cyber Monday thing where you
can go and for the next three days
including Monday Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday and shipping no matter where
you live no matter what you buy is $3
per order so a note international orders
can take a very long time so if you're
expecting to get them for Christmas you
probably should not expect that my glass
is you notice that these are the same
old glasses well that's because the
world is annoying first I had to go get
a new prescription so I went to Walmart
when they gave you the wrong
prescription literally like wrote down
the numbers wrong second LensCrafters
after getting the new prescription made
the glasses wrong they just had the
wrong prescriptions in the lenses I
don't know why there's no control in
this field like cursed in the mall
yesterday when I was trying to pick up
my glasses and they were wrong infernal
little kids I said the f-word in front
of these little kids because I was so
frustrated frustrated was not the F word
I use project for awesome is happening
once again like every year December 17th
and 18th and we will need you to make
videos to curate videos and to promote
videos on December 17th and 18th so
clear your schedules people John that's
all I've got going on right now that's
not true at all I've golf's we've got
the scishow and crash course things and
a couple of other things and other
things but as long as I have time to
play Super Mario Brothers Wii with my
wife all is good in the world John I'll
see you on Wednesday